megan the duchess of sussex says she is
grateful that a british tabloid is being
held accountable for what she calls
dehumanized dehumanizing practices
that's how you say that word
this follows a court ruling stop it
anthony
i wasn't doing anything this fall does
my bad this follows a court ruling that
the owner of the mail on sunday
newspaper and dailymail.com
violated her right to privacy by
publishing a very personal letter that
she wrote to her dad
after she married prince harry as
charlie dagetta reports
the case shows how privacy laws in
britain are very different from the u.s
in a stunning legal victory for the
duchess of sussex
a high court judge ruled that publishing
extracts of that letter was
a manifestly excessive and thus unlawful
breach of privacy
in a statement megan called the decision
a comprehensive win
for these outlets it's a game for me and
so many others it's
real life real relationships and very
real sadness
the damage they have done and continue
to do runs deep
what we're seeing is london becoming the
privacy capital of the world
media lawyer mark stevens said the
ruling underscores the growing
schism between british and american
privacy laws
had it been published in the us he says
megan wouldn't have had a case
i think what it'll mean is that american
media have an advantage they'll be
reporting more
the public will learn more and citizens
from this country are going to start
looking
at the american media in order to get
the unvarnished news
the case centered on a personal letter
published in the mail on sunday
newspaper from megan to her estranged
father thomas markle
after his no-show at her royal wedding
where she accused him of breaking her
heart for talking to british tabloids
the judge's ruling avoids what might
have been a messy
public trial pitting megan against her
father
in court i know at buckingham palace um
there is relief because they never
wanted this to go all the way to trial
because it
would have put megan on the stand royal
aids on the stand
and what would have come out then
potentially would have been incredibly
damaging
now it's an open question whether this
will serve as a warning shot to other
british media and the largely
negative coverage of the couple as for
the publishers they say they're
surprised
and disappointed by the decision and
they're considering an appeal
gail all right charlie dagger thank you
i thought megan made a really good point
when she said for some this is a game
but for me it's real life yes a lot of
damage has been done one part of the
ruling seemed to say
that megan had the right to expect
privacy in a letter that
a personal letter that she wrote to her
dad yeah the privacy laws in england are
very strict yeah it'll be interesting to
see if this is
this will be a game changer thank you
again charlie dagetta reporting from
london